all right all of our jurors are here
please be seated
morning everyone happy friday we're
gonna continue now with the
cross-examination of mr goodwin officer
can you call in mr goodwin please
so
mr goodwin we need to re-administer the
oath this morning since we broke for the
day left hand on a michael please raise
your right hand do you swear in the
presence of almighty god that the
testimony you give to this court
regarding this matter shall be the truth
the whole truth and nothing but the
truth yes you did please state your name
i'll spell your last name for the record
robert goodwin g-o-o-d-w-i-n
thank you all right you may have a seat
mr goodwin
council
mr goodwin when we broke yesterday we
were talking about uh
the secret recordings that you and
lauren cataract made to recall that
conversation i do
and so
i'm clear
you lauren cataract and her father
knew
that
you were secretly recording
conversations correct
uh
i i know
does lauren know
well i think she was aware at some point
yes
well wasn't it lauren's idea
to secretly record these conversations
oh that was my idea
did you talk to her about your idea
uh
may have brought it up
you may have may have brought it up
after
work when did you
bring it up
i'm not sure today
did you discuss the recordings with her
father
i'm sure i may have
and
did you have a discussion with anyone
prior to starting those recordings as to
whether or not they were legal
objection
what's the relevance mr blinkist move on
that question is stricken move on now
you testified
yesterday
that every single
recording
you made in this stable area and i'm
referring to that big
building that includes where the horses
are housed the club room and the office
we're made from lauren cataract's locker
now
did you meet with an attorney edward
david
on
august
6th
and did you discuss with him these
recordings
i do not recall
you have no recollection of discussing i
do not
so
i show you d 100 r 1
which is a transcript
of the recording that you made and ask
you to take a look at that
and see if that refreshes your
recollection as to on august 6th
at the lawyer's office did you and
lauren talk about these recordings
i mean
this isn't all transcripts though
i understand that
but does that refresh her recollection
as to whether or not
you lauren canorack
and her father were in a lawyer's office
discussing these recordings
judge for the record while mr goodwin's
reading that is pages 48 and 49 of 128
just so the record's clicked
have you reviewed the transcript mr
[Applause]
did you finish i did all right mr
goodwin finished ask a question does
that refresh your recollection as to
whether or not you
lauren canarack her father
and the attorney were talking about
your secret recordings
um yeah they were speaking about it i
mentioned uh
i don't know not what you mentioned just
it's a yes or no question just answer
and then wait for the follow-up question
and
during that meeting did lauren can iraq
mention
that
she had a recording where the recordings
were made in her locker as you have
testified to
yes i put the recordings in my locker
okay and lauren cataract tells
that to the lawyer correct
yes
and then after she says that
did you say
at least
at least that recording anyway
ha ha
and now you took the paper
[Music]
i'm sorry where is it
oh
that says speaker one i don't know if
that's me
for the record that
i'll stipulate for a purpose this
exercise that that is mr goodwin's voice
all right ladies and gentlemen there is
a stipulation
that speaker one as referenced by mr
goodwin is in fact mr uh goodwin it's
just not labeled as such in the
transcript
it's it's labeled speaker one but it is
in fact according to the stipulations mr
goodwin speaking did you make that
statement
as i did yes
now
yesterday
you were asked by the prosecutor whether
or not you owned a gun
correct correct
and
your answer was no correct okay
did you ever post
a picture of a nine millimeter handgun
on your facebook
account
perhaps
can we be heard a sidebar your honor
sure
i show you what has been marked d 103
which is a facebook
record of your account
and ask you to take a look at that
do we have a date mr belinkus yes judge
for context please
february 22nd
2018 and there's a picture that attached
to it can you look at both of those
please
okay
did you post a picture of a nine minute
nine millimeter handgun
on that day
it appears to be yes
when you say it appears to be
i don't remember
did you indicate in the
comments section regarding that gun that
there were bullets for that gun
i did
[Music]
now you indicated yesterday that you're
not really familiar with guns correct
i don't know if i said i was unfamiliar
with them or i'm not a gun guy
what's the difference in your mind
i mean i've used guns before and how to
use a gun you know about gun safety
for instance you're a marine correct
you were trained with
inspector weapons correct
and hand-to-hand combat correct
yesterday
on direct examination
you said you turned off your blank
cameras correct correct when did you do
that
i don't recall when i was going up and
down the hallway
how many days before the
shooting
i think the camera was hooked up for one
day
and when did you hook it up
approximately so the day before the
junior
and sometime during that afternoon i
turned it off
the day before the shooting no sometime
that day of this shooting
the shooting occurred somewhere around
uh
two o'clock correct
yes
do you recall receiving
at approximately 142
a clip from your blank camera
do i re no
why would i recall that
please
[Music]
mr goodwin i show you d 100 c 14
1
and refer you to
august 7.
[Music]
can you look at those notations on there
uh
this is obviously really small
judge can we be heard at sidebar while
the witness is looking at that is it
sure
do we have a magnifying glass or
come on
let's clarify your last question please
mr goodwin
you have no idea according to your
testimony correctly if i'm wrong
that when you turned off this blink
camera correct
uh correct i stated that um
i was going through the hallway the
lauren was sitting outside so the camera
was
making notification sounds constantly so
i turned it off sometime during
that
now
the day that the
town came
which was august 6th
and kicked michael barrasson out of the
staple
on that day
the camera was working correct
i don't recall
specifically okay well didn't you send a
clip
of ruth cox
entering the farmhouse
to warren cataract
on the seven
uh
that's probably so
well i'll show you 100 c 14 1
and ask if that refreshes your
recollection
is it the bottom one we're talking about
oh how many of them are there on there
i mean what
well
are you refreshing his recollection
point of view
well i understand that because he was
confused so if you're asking him to
refresh his recollection with a specific
item on on a page full of them point out
which lines he's obviously asking what
line
again
you look at this and this
as to who you sent it to who did you
send
the blank clip
from the six to
this is your my number and lawrence
number
okay and
now that you see this document do you
recall
having a blank
video
of some image
on the sixth that you sent to
lauren county yeah i specifically
remembered a video where uh ruth came
into my house
so on the sixth we know what was working
correct correct
now
right before the shooting
did you hear lauren cataract
say
to michael barrisson
something about
objection
seriously today
right before the shooting judge i think
it's part of the
what
mr goodwin
after you
had your conversation with michael
barrison
on the day in question
right before the shooting
your girlfriend lauren counteract comes
outside correct
she walks past you correct
did you hear any conversation between
her
and michael barisson
i did
and what did you hear
not word for word but i think she wanted
to
figure out how we can fix it how we can
fix the situation
lauren said she wanted to fix it where
michael barrasson said
no michael spoke to me and lauren said
i'll talk to him you know if he wants to
fix it
okay she said that to you or to michael
barrasso
she said i'll talk to him to me
um
and she didn't get to say much to
michael before he pulled up the gun he
wasn't there for a conversation
hold on don't
just answer the question okay
okay go ahead when you say she didn't
say much i'm asking you specifically
you were right there correct i think she
got in the middle of the sentence and he
shot
her what was she saying
at the time she was shot i'm not 100
sure
irrespective of whether you're sure no
he said he's not sure
what do you want him to say
did you ever tell the police
in your official statement that night
that lauren canaract
spoke to michael barrasso
she didn't i'm saying i'm not sure what
she said
my question is
did you tell the police
that lauren cataract
said anything to
barristone before
he shot her i'm not 100 sure
now this arrangement that
was made with regards to trading your
work for
living accommodations
at some point in time did you give
michael barroso a bill for your work
uh
before the shooting now
did you discuss with lauren cataract and
her father
you giving barristone a bill for your
work
i definitely discussed with lauren since
the horses that were supposed to be
there
a good time before the actually the one
horse got there
saying i'd like to get caught up and
send him a bill since the forces did not
come
and
did lauren tell you that if you did that
you would undermine our entire plan and
ruin everything
what's that
did lauren tell you in response to that
that if you did you would undermine
their entire plan
and ruin everything
i think what was mentioned when we
talked about the bill was that
she wanted to use that for training of
the horses
so she did not want me to give a bill
she wanted to train the horses and do
you recall her telling you that if you
did you would ruin
your plan with her i just said what i
recalled
[Music]
uh
eh
[Music]
i'll show you what is with mark d 200
c27
and ask you to refer to
item 6303
and i'm going to give you my glasses
here
6303
can you can you read that and tell me
if this refreshes your recollection as
to whether or not
okay
but she's already answered this question
i'm not sure what memory is being
refreshed here mr blink because he did
answer the question whether or not he
had a conversation with lauren about if
he did this it would ruin their plan
he said he did
all right that's my recollection but go
ahead does that refresh your
recollection as to whether or not you
had that conversation with ward well
lauren sent me a text message and i just
explained what i remembered
[Music]
when you had that conversation with
lauren can iraq
um did she express hold on you're
referring to a text message
no i'm referring to the conversation
that he said he remembered having
with regards to that conversation
were you and lauren cataract concerned
about you losing your living
accommodations on the farm
not at all
baby
now
did you and
lauren cataract have a and the father
have a conversation about
scaring michael barrisson
i don't recall a very vague question
did you ever intend
on scaring michael barrison i don't know
that refers to
making him afraid of
lord i do not believe so
i show you d200c31
the problem is i can't see when i give
you my classes i had them the other day
i didn't need it so i didn't think i
could bring them in 49-14
can you please look at that
and that's a conversation between you
and the father and
cataract lauren correct
when you say conversation mr blankens
let's let's be clear conversation has a
certain meaning
all right so if it's a text message
please refer to it as a text message so
there's no confusion for the jurors or
for the record thank you
is this a text message to me is that
what it looks like
yes
so what's the question
does that refresh your recollection as
to whether or not in a text message
you
lauren cataract and her father
were discussing
having to
scare michael barristone
judge i have the same objection that
this is hearsay
it has to do with the threat
hold on
[Music]
mr goodwin
were you aware that
lauren
cataract had gotten access to michael
barrasson's office
and taken certain things from it i was
not aware
judge i'm going to renew the same
objection i made when this was brought
up yesterday and i think you oh
no i i understand that he said no
okay and i tend to use this to impeach
him
show it to mr shellhorn
judge can we come to cyborg
[Music]
for the record the objection um
was overlooked with my limiting
instructions
i'm going to show you a text message
from warren counteract to you
on july 11 2019
and i'm going to refer you specifically
to item number 4844
and ask you to read that to see if it
refreshes your recollection with regards
to whether or not you were aware that
loren tanarak had access to
michael barrasson's office on that day
i don't know this is in
regards to
i don't understand your answer
i i read the text
i read the text
and it's your testimony that that
doesn't refresh your recollection as to
whether or not you were aware i i your
girlfriend had access to michael
barrasson's office
i don't understand why i just got access
to michael's office did michael say you
could go into my office i don't
understand that all right move on mr
blinkist
there's no context
now
when
to your knowledge
uh
did michael barrisson or anyone
associated with his company
ask you
when warren to leave the property
i think there was a general sense of
wanting us to leave but
i don't think to the uh
i don't think until the attorney was
involved is when
when it was considered serious
on july 25th 2019
were you concerned that you were going
to be thrown off the property on that
day
i mean like it's like i said there's a
little bit of uh
of tension but
they didn't ask us to leave i don't
think with that date
when you say a little bit of tension
would you agree with me that
it was a lot more than a little bit
i could tell you i didn't really
understand what the problem was
but you did understand that there was in
fact a problem with your girlfriend
and basically everyone at
michael
barrissone's facility
correct
i think you'd have to ask them but i
understood there were to be a
problem which was an uncomfortable
situation okay
she had a problem with justin harden
based on your observations correct
but yes i mean but they talked
afterwards so no i mean
i mean are you asking if justin hated
her i couldn't i couldn't tell you no
he's not he's not asking that question
and don't don't don't speak about that
based on your observations between your
girlfriend and justin harding
i said she she wasn't happy with the way
justin wrote evie the horse the one
horsey yeah and was there a problem
based on your observations with your
girlfriend and mary haskins there was
something going on between them
now when you say something going on
you were aware of
numerous
facebook facebook postings that your
girlfriend posted
disparaging
people that worked at
the facility correct i mean i don't
think they liked each other okay
i can't see each but you were aware of
certain attacks by your girlfriend on
social media against these people
correct
someone
yeah when you say these people i'm not
sure that's right that's could
i'm unclear of what the problem was
between those two so
at any point during this
situation
[Music]
did
lord cataract
declare war against them
to your knowledge i i don't know how
about the father do you recall the
father ever say
yeah again this is hearsay mr balencas
objections sustained
did lauren cataract
ever
suggest
that you punch mary haskins in the face
you rephrase him
judge i think this is hearsay as well
well i'm looking for the next
item
you'll agree with me that
with respect to everything that was
going on
there were communications
either by text message or emails
between you
lauren cataract and her father
throughout the entire time correct
it's very
i mean
it's very vague but yes there are there
are text threads of me lauren and
jonathan
like for instance with regards to you
turning
michael barris on into the town and
having been kicked out of the stables
prior to that
you talked to lauren cataract and the
father about that correct i don't recall
specifically
so
i'll show you d 100 14
specifically
751
is that a text message between you
lauren cataract and
the father
regarding
you going to the town
the text message from jonathan
jonathan is who
oh lauren's fault and it's both you and
lauren correct am i written in the right
line
yeah okay next question
does that refresh your recollection as
to whether at least with regards to you
turning
michael barissone into the town
and getting him kicked out that you
lauren and the father discuss that
intentionally i do see the text message
here yes
and just every pressure recollection as
to whether you talked about that prior
to it happening
i think that is the day that it happened
but prior to the actual
town coming correct i think it's the day
if i i brought the paper over there
and they came what the next day i
believe so
now why why did you turn michael
barrasso into the town
uh all my work throughout the year i
didn't receive one one cent
and if he was trying to if
communications broke down to the point
where i felt like we were leaving and
there was no communication of paying for
my services
it was in a uh
it's kind of a way to repossess my work
i
thought they were gonna come in and and
give him a fine and he was gonna have to
pay it and then go through inspection
processes
and when we first started this process
especially at the barn
i told michael as the owner
he can pull permits legally he doesn't
need to be a licensed contractor
i show you 102.
is this the letter that
you brought to the town
[Music]
and
it is
and and who wrote this letter you were
flooring i dictated to lauren
now
you indicated that you sent this letter
because uh
at that point you
didn't think you were going to get paid
for your work
several reasons what are the other
reasons uh one the the fire hazard with
a barn that was left on overnight and
the
refusal to turn it off although while
the girl was heading up to sleep
um
and then uh
and code violations
you've been working there for a year and
a half
why all of a sudden did code violations
bother you
it's not my responsibility to file
permits the owners
my question is why did you wait a year
and a half
to file this letter with the town
i just told you our deal
was not going through so there was no
payment no form of payment for my work
had you
you hadn't given michael barcelona bill
correct no
assure that
the agreement was traded for the
training of the horses
if you brought it up earlier that
lauren wasn't happy with that deal
and when you save the agreement
trading for the horses
the whole time you were living in
his house
free of charge
other than what's paid for boarding
forces correct
the agreement to live in the house let's
do
upend our lives to go train with michael
from the original agreement of bringing
the two horses all inclusive
when you say upend your lives
is in effect that lauren cataract
saw the possibility of training with the
world class versage olympian
was to her advantage
to her advantage
you're asking him about
ms canorack's state of mind
he just made a statement as to why he
came
up end our lives so abandon our life
would it be better for your life
specifically
not at all
were you living in nicer accommodations
up there
in north carolina yes
now
i show you d100e 1a
isn't it a fact that on
[Music]
june 18th
you submitted a bill
june 18 2019.
you submitted a bill to michael
barrasson for your work that was not
submitted now
did you did you write that up
i did write that up
why would you write up a bill and not
submit it to pariso
the text message you referred to from
lauren about
not giving a bill that's why he didn't
get the bill
so you agreed with your girlfriend not
to charge him for the work that you were
doing correct
i agree not to receive cash payment
correct
and that was your choice
at that point
correct
it's a mutual decision between me and
lauren
and then when
problems become
isn't it the fact that you tried to
collect 50
000
for your work
i think the number was in the 20s but
i'm not exactly sure
are you aware of the fact
i'm going to object
you see itself
injection sustained i don't find it
relevant under 401 and excludable under
403 as well
goodwin
on august 6th
were you notified that michael
barrison's lawyer
had sent a letter
telling you and lauren to get out
of the home
are you asking if i was aware of it
august 6
yes i'm not 100 sorry
were you aware that a uh
strike then
august 6
were you aware
that michael barristone's attorney sent
a letter
to lauren and her father
telling them to get out
again i'm not aware exactly of august's
fifth or whatever whatever what day we
received the letter from the attorney
okay but you will agree with me that
on august 5th
is the day you went to the town to try
to get him kicked out of his
august august 5th is when i dropped the
letter off correct
were you aware that a
formal eviction
complaint was served on august 6th i was
not i don't think there was any eviction
taking place
now
when the town came on
august 6 the day before the shooting
did you show them uh different areas and
point things out to them
i do not believe so
did you talk about
strike that
did you
personally talk to town officials
about
specific items
i believe when
there was a discussion on
august 5th when i dropped off the ladder
and who did you have that discussion
with
one of the clerks
and
you were one of the contractors working
correct
uh
that was doing some construction there
when you said you were doing
construction weren't you doing tens of
thousands of dollars of work for michael
barista in exchange for you being able
to live there
and board horses so apparently i was
doing free construction
you admit that
no no no sorry let me rephrase that okay
apparently i did construction that i did
not get paid for one cent
and and that was something that
lauren
and her dad
agreed
to have you do with michael barrasso
correct not correct
well for instance when
you wanted to submit a bill it was
lauren
not michael barrasson that convinced you
not
to submit that bill correct
lauren talked me into accepting another
form of payment but as i said yesterday
in florida me and michael discussed
whatever is left over can go towards
payment towards me
when you say left over would you agree
that well the horses
would you agree that on the day of the
shooting
the
farmhouse
was
far
far from being
fully completed
so were the apartments that michael was
building above the barn for two years
doesn't mean the work took place during
that time
did you ever
specifically
instigate
shit
with michael
i don't know we're referring to
did you ever attempt to instigate an
altercation
with michael barrasso
at any point
did i instigate it i didn't i do not
attempt to instigate i
don't believe so
i show you what has been marked 100 c 14
5
and ask you if this refreshes your
recollection
and i'm referring you to item
199. first
text on top
chris you have a copy for
this is the texture warren i believe
that
i'm just asking you does that refresh
your life
recollection as to whether or not you
ever intentionally
tried to institute
an altercation with michael barrison no
i don't know what does that reference to
did you ever threaten ruth cox
no
you never
threatened her at the barn
telling her that she was gonna
go down
objection judge
please rephrase your question
do you remember an instance of that this
stable area
where you got into an argument with
michael barrison
i remember one internship and
was ruth cox there
no i believe so
you don't have any recollection of uh
a threat being made
where michael barrasson and ruth cox are
together
i don't believe uh ruth cox was there
when me and michael had a uh uh
an argument about jt the horse and not
going to the show
did you get very loud and were you
yelling with regards to that above
louder yelling
i'm referring to you did you get loud
and were you screaming at michael
i got loud
now
with report with regards to
your discussions with lauren cataract
and the father
about
calling the town
and getting michael barriston
kicked
out of the area that he was now living
in
did you tell them
well let's hope this doesn't backfire on
me
did you make that statement that is
correct and at the time i wasn't 100 i
was in the clear
when i followed the report
now
you're currently suing michael barriston
correct objection
you already rolled on this your honor
i'm not talking
i'm not talking about construction judge
what
don't specify what you're talking about
then are you suing michael barrasson for
anything related to the shooting
me no
you're not involved in that lawsuit
were you aware of lauren cataract's plan
at any point in time prior to the
shooting
her plan
to destroy michael barrasson
no
did michael barrisson
ever
threaten you
i don't think so
did michael barrasson to your knowledge
ever threaten lauren cataract i'm not
sure
well didn't you tell the police
no
that
he never threatened warren counteracts
talking about in his presence
any knowledge that he has
do you have any knowledge i'm not sure
what
do you have any knowledge whatsoever
from any source
that michael barriston ever threatened
lauren cataract
uh nothing's coming to my mind but i
believe it would be a question for
lauren
you guys have been together for how long
very long time
i assume you talk about things on a
daily basis
would be it correct
did lauren cataract ever mention to you
that her life was being corrected
again i do not recall that specifically
got a question for lauren i believe
now
on the morning of this
seventh did you have an altercation with
the blacksmith
i don't believe so
did you get into an argument with him
blacksmith's name
i do not believe so no i don't think
i've ever had a bad moment with arnie
did you see arnie
on the morning
of the shooting
i don't recall
was there an instance where
judges already indicated multiple times
he doesn't recall
did you attempt to have if there's a way
to refresh his recollection but i would
object to any specific questions being
asked where he's just said that he
doesn't have any recollection
judge if i can answer them let me see
let me see that sidebar
the jurors said that i guess the
prosecutors they had stuff that's
hold on hold on come on
it's a good one
talking about
august 7th 2019 the day of the shooting
is it your testimony that you don't
recall having an issue
with the farrier blacksmith on that
morning i do not specifically remember
seeing or talking to the pair
i'm going to show you
d100c-15
which is a text message from your phone
to lauren cataract
and can you look at
item eight and nine
okay it appears that uh
evie might have supposed to get shot
that day
i think i know what this is
okay and does that refresh a
recollection about
there being a
issue with the ferrier blacksmith on
that day
it was a very very simple issue
um
it may have been scheduled to
put shoes on our horses and
i guess uh
from what i recall is that michael told
him not to show our horses anymore
and
when michael right there
when the farrier told you
that michael said not to shoo the horses
did you make a physical threat against
michael barrison
i do not recall
specifically
did you communicate this issue
and problem to lauren cataract on that
day
i'm sure i may have spoke about her
horses not being shot that day
what possibility when you say it's a
possibility doesn't your text directly
address that issue
with lauren cataract
i see the text i do not specifically
remember
the text or
sending me text on that day
but i can see it's there
and
during that discussion
did lauren cataract tell you to finish
the bastard
meaning michael barrison objection
sustained
now
with all the recording that you were uh
doing
in the stable area
um
were you aware that michael
barrison had hired a debugging company
to try to find the recordings
how would i be aware of that
so your answer is no no just answer the
question please
were you aware that he hired a private
security guard
to sit in his truck at night
and guard the stable area no
you never saw a guy's truck
outside all night long
in front or the side of the street i've
seen i've seen a car i believe alarm
called 9-1-1
at the time it was going up there but
now i was never up there at that time to
witness
a security guard
or know the security guard was there
did you hear them talking about hiring a
security guard you cannot recall
with regards to the
incident
when michael barristone
came down from the stable area
you were on the telephone with your
lawyer correct correct
were you planning on
filing a lawsuit against michael
barrissone before
i think i think the purpose of the
attorney was to work out and continue
our original
deal
that we had i mean
when you say the original deal
everything had deteriorated to the point
of no return correct
that is that's true
and it's your testimony that
the reason
you called the attorney was to try to
keep things going at the facility
i mean i'm i'm not sure
what the arrangement between lauren and
the attorney was
i mean
she was
more involved with it than i was okay
why did you call the attorney on that
day
i think he called me
all right so
you're on the phone with the attorney
and you're upstairs in the bedroom
correct correct
and at some point you hear
lauren calling for you correct correct
now
at that point nothing had happened
correct
no she was informing me that michael was
pulling michael was there
okay when you say informing you
was she screaming
she said rob michael's here
and did that cause you any concern
no
even in light of the fact that you got
him kicked out of the stable did you
think about that
i mean
concern about
him murdering us no
i mean confrontation
yes
i mean at that point i didn't know he
was at the house though either
you know she said michael was here and
that's all i
well i didn't understand any context of
you know what it was i came downstairs
and when you used the term con
confrontation
you saw
a confrontation between michael
barrisson and your girlfriend
on a previous occasion correct
i don't know what that's in reference to
do you ever do you ever did you ever see
your girlfriend
get into michael barrasson's face
push him back 20 feet to his car him
trying to leave
and her
grabbing his door shutting it refusing
to allow him to leave
did you
i don't think i was president if that
happened
you never saw that
did you hold on this yes yeah and then
move on mr blinkist
so
lauren cataract says
michael is here
and and
you're still on the phone with the
attorney correct correct
you walk down
you open the door
and you
step onto the landing correct that's
correct now prior to you walking outside
did you hand the phone
to lauren
i did at the bottom of the steps before
we came outside pretty much
pretty much either somewhere in the
laundry room or right as i got down the
steps from my apartment okay so when you
say down the steps you're talking about
the steps inside
not outside correct correct correct
so lauren is inside at this point
you walk out
onto the landing
on top of the steps in the back of the
house
correct
okay
did you shut the door
uh i think lawrence may have shut the
door i don't know she was right behind
me okay and
according to you
michael says
can't we work this out
i don't want to go to war
that's correct
now or how how can we work this out i
don't want a war okay
now
would you agree with me that when he
said that he was calm
i agree you look normal yes
um
you've described him as sorrowful
correct
excuse me
you've described him
[Music]
as sorrowful
isn't that a fact i don't believe
so i don't know what we're referring to
okay
at what point
at which point in time you say
something to the effect
lawyers are involved
you know they'll resolve it correct
i
said he uh
he brought lawyers into so the lawyers
can handle it
now
at that point in time
you
turn your back
and start walking away from michael
barriston correct
when did lauren cataract
come outside well i think she was behind
me
um she said she'll she'll go talk to him
she wanted to try to i guess work
something out
when you say work something out
i don't know what it was in regards to
would you agree with me that
at that point she was
pissed off
before she even said anything to
barrister
are you asking how i feel what lawrence
no asking you your observations of
lauren cataract was she angry that she
she wanted to i don't know what she was
trying to work out i mean in my mind
there was nothing to work out
but she said
you know she wanted to work something
out
i guess she at least wanted to hear what
he had to say
did she casually walk down to talk to
him or did she stomp her way
towards him
walked over though
she came down the steps and walked over
towards him
okay and you
[Music]
did you go into the house i stayed there
on the porch watching the conversation
or
watching what i thought was going to be
a conversation
so
after the shooting she didn't
run up the stairs
open the door and yell to you
not to come out
you say it again
okay
after you talk to michael barriston
and lauren cataract walked
down the stairs to talk to michael
did she
after that
walk up the stairs
open the door
and tell you
don't come out
no
were you present when she made her
statement to the prosecutor's office
did you talk to her about the events and
what happened on that night prior to her
giving the statement to the prosecutor
he did not
i know we we've talked many times about
the incident it was a very life-changing
incident and unfortunately i will never
forget or get over
so i mean
i don't understand did i coach her are
you saying i know i'm not
before
she went to talk to the prosecutor and
give her official version of the
event
i don't think so it's instructed i think
not to
by
who by the police i believe
when
i don't know lauren was in the hospital
for three weeks
sometimes in that three weeks i i think
i was told somewhere along the line
not to discuss
yeah
and it's your
it's your testimony that after she got
out of the hospital
and came home that you and her never
talked about that day what happened who
did what
what
each other's recollection was
i just said i'm not i'm not sure
specifically what was talked about and
when was talked about it but it was a
major
life-changing event that lauren
unfortunately will have to live with
problems for the rest of her life
because a man
shot her
two times unprovoked
tried to kill me and her
and so as far as your recollection is
concerned
you have no
recollection of lauren after you talk to
michael
coming
to the back door opening up and yelling
for you not to come out
i was outside i witnessed the whole
thing
when you say you witnessed the whole
thing
didn't you tell the police you heard the
shots of course i heard the shots i also
watched the shots
mr belinkus is this a good time to take
on morning recess it's 10 of 11 all
right
very good ladies and gentlemen we'll
take our 15 minute uh morning recess
we'll resume about 5 after 11 or as
close as possible thank you
you can step outside just stay down this
end of the hallway all right
thank you
and don't discuss the case with anyone
you